welcome ping welcome to this video poco
poco a poco what is he going for a whoa
that is not very exciting some kind of
yeah that's an even more passive college
system than than usual okay I'm this is
basically a reverse Catalan now and it's
not even having an extra tempo funny but
again the position is of course very
solid for white I cannot expect to have
a big advantage with black yeah 93 now
it should be equal
well here I don't know there are
scenarios where something like a sex
queen f6 I might use the the C 3 square
and then but it's really nothing check
he cannot develop this night easily this
is some a little bit of an annoyance
okay so i have 93 now or not nights no
i'm also in a pin
hmm
yeah nothing really nothing possible
here from a technical point of view
cats really would you just equal what
can you do
huh that's a bit boring
but quite sure why he would give me the
d file well okay OOP t1 is giving away
the h2porn so so here I can take on f3 I
have maybe he will take the night yeah
maybe a 95 doesn't really do much I can
takes it while I can go to see two
however c2 mmm staten IDM Roxy one
that's really complicated quite
unnecessarily complicated okay but now
if I take it it's really just a draw now
if you forgive us with you one half srf
to take that all
yeah and I said it's a it's from me he
doesn't even take the light yeah why by
calculating a single variation never
they never play what I calculate never
ever ever okay well not that this is
terrible for him or so but it would be
fun to at least once in a while have the
liner played against shoot that you
actually had calculated before hand 95
okay rookie to as a very cheap trick but
now maybe look to see three hmm yeah
yeah it's a little it's a little
something
it's a little something it's not so easy
to play now repealing I go here night c
1 is a threat
hmm check okay white forfeits due to
disconnection yeah okay so it was
surprising that this went downhill so
quickly yeah here this is just just very
chat warring equality yeah I think that
was all kind of logical looking it's
really just nothing nothing going on
this is this and and it's equal ish we
could have played Knight b6 I didn't see
that one that is so hang and take six
digs they were Pawn down I was lucky he
didn't do that he took on d 8 and there
was a mysterious move anyway giving me
the D file but it's not equal I for
thinking that this is this the idea but
yeah counter checking with with a look
here but ok this is Jack a move that I
did not see yeah this is good Jim he's
tied to that poor now so this is
probably right then look here yeah I'm
having a slight initiative even though
it's nothing nothing terrible yeah 94
now was okay that's an interesting line
I didn't see that one 94 rook takes 90
to end it's a perpetual I know it's not
perpetual
I can go here and now ninety four nights
where I thought it he has a he could
turn pursue the rook anyway you went thi
and that's no good okay thanks for
watching